good morning believe nation today's
message is be proactive over to you
IceCube and I'm doing my career my way
you know being able to put together your
own movies is a blessing you know most
actors are just sitting around waiting
for somebody to say hey you want to be
in my movie so I don't like that I would
I wouldn't be active if I was just
sitting around so I love producing I
love writing and just making sure it
happened you gotta be proactive so what
do you think I think that it's so
important to be proactive in order to
achieve your dreams for the longest time
I was working for other law firms other
lawyers just getting so frustrated with
the decisions that they were making not
understanding them the consequences of
their decisions and then one day I
decided to be proactive and look into
what I could do for myself rather than
relying on others to take me where I
wanted to go I remember the one of the
only jobs that I've ever had I'm having
any job so one of them I was doing data
entry like in University trying to get
work your way in between data entry and
I got so upset with my boss because they
wouldn't let me have snacks and they
wouldn't let me listen to music and I
was doing more work than the rest of my
team combined like I wouldn't take lunch
breaks I just worked for everything but
they wouldn't let me have snacks or
listen to music so I kept like my
popcorn in the first drawer and would
like always sneak some popcorn and then
I would put a discman back in the day a
dis man on the fledging of this man this
man back on the on the floor in my
cubicle and then ran a wire up my jeans
through my turtleneck and had a little
earbud popping out just so I could
listen to music cuz it was like some
soul-crushing stuff and I thought this
is ridiculous right like I'm so much
more productive to anybody else to my
team and I can't eat popcorn or
listening to music it's like okay I got
it
I got a bet on myself it's the best but
you can make instead of putting your
hands in
somebody else's you know control and now
you need popcorn all day now can you
popcorn all day and I love it I should
get some popcorn right now so the
questions of a today is how are you
gonna be proactive today
today what are you gonna do today to be
proactive leaving the comments below
will join the discussion thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
a vinspresso